depuis plus d'un an maintenant la
pandémie de kovy de ferrage et au fil
des mois de nombreux cas d'animaux qui
attrape le virus ont été signalés parmi
eux les visons qu'on élève pour leur
fourrure les cas de coronavirus dans ces
élevages sont loin d'être isolé ce qui
soulève beaucoup de questions une mise
en garde ici certaines images peuvent
choquer
et
si la pandémie nous a appris quelque
chose c'est qu'il faut penser une seule
santé il faut monique tories les agents
infectieux chez toutes les espèces
animales le risque d'épidémie augmentent
on ne doit pas céder à la panique mais
prendre cela au sérieux ce sont les
images d'une hécatombe
en novembre dernier le danemark premiers
éleveurs de visons au monde prenait des
mesures draconiennes aux 17 millions de
visons sont abattus et enterrés à la
hâte dans les fermes ce sont d'abord des
travailleurs qui infecte et les animaux
mais en se transmettant chez les visons
danois le virus mute il repasse ensuite
chez les humains
la détection de cette mutation du
coronavirus au sein de la communauté s
et les autorités danoises à déclencher
l'abattage massif des visons au créa
alors que les vaccins ne soient pas
efficaces contre ces nouvelles mutations
me cheptels entiers sacrifier certains
animaux comme les chats et les chiens
sont susceptibles d'attraper la co vide
les visons sont particulièrement
vulnérables à ce type de virus
respiratoires ils développent des
symptômes très similaires à ceux des
humains et leur taux de mortalité est
aussi semblable au nôtre dans les fermes
d'élevage où des milliers d'animaux sont
côte à côte dans des cages la densité de
population contribue à créer les
conditions idéales pour la propagation
du virus
c'est comme chez les humains si vous
rassembler un grand nombre de personnes
une maladie peut se propager à vitesse
grand v
la néerlandaise marion kauffman est une
sommité mondiale de la virologie
dès le mois d'avril elle assiste à la
propagation de lakovic 19 dans des
élevages aux pays bas c'est le premier
pays d'europe ou des visons sont
infectés ben on a vu d'abord une ferme
puis deux puis trois qui tentaient de
maîtriser l'infection ça s'est avéré
très difficile pour des raisons qui nous
échappent encore aujourd'hui et pour la
première fois des scientifiques
documente la transmission du virus d'une
espèce animale aux humains les pays bas
qui pour des raisons éthiques devait
mettre fin à l élevage de visons en 2024
devant cette échéance plus de deux
millions de visons sont abattues de
manière préventive les éleveurs sont
compensées imaginez si ça avait été des
bovins ou des porcs l'histoire serait
très différente
c'est tragique côte en devises ont été
tués et des élevages et dû fermer mais
si c'était des animaux destinés à la
consommation
ce serait encore plus difficile - des
faits quand on estime qu'il y ait en
europe plus de 2700 ferme de vison qui
produisent de façon intensive 27
millions de pots par annie quatre
sentiers ferme ont enregistré des
éclosions de co vide et dans trois pays
des cas de transmission des visons aux
humains ont été observés les etats unis
qui élèvent 3 millions de vison par
année ne sont pas épargnés au mois
d'août un élevage en utah est infecté en
tout une quinzaine d'éclosion sont
rapportés dans les 275 ferme que compte
le pays
début décembre 2020 c'est au tour du
canada qui élève un million de vison de
signaler des cas de co vide dans les
fermes
on s'y attendait parce que la coved et
représente seulement 2 des 79 fermes
d'élevage du canada sont infectés elles
sont situées dans la vallée du fleuve
phrase air à chilliwack en
colombie-britannique et elle abritait
environ 20000 visons 230 succombent à
l'aco vide
aucun des éleveurs concernés n'a voulu
nous accorder d'entrevue mais le
président des éleveurs de visons du
canada dont la ferme est située en
nouvelle écosse nous explique que la
situation en europe avait mis
l'industrie sur un pied d'alerté
la plupart des fermes ont vraiment
renforcer les mesures de biosécurité
il n'y a que le personnel absolument
nécessaire quitte à demi parce que la
plus grande menace
si on y met leur ventre et ont dit
n'être la possible propagation du virus
si dans la première ferme canadiennes se
sont bien travailleurs atteindre la
coved qui ont infecté les animaux
personne n'arrive à expliquer comment
les visons de la deuxième ferme située à
moins de 8 kilomètres ont pu attraper la
co vide et aux pays-bas docteur coupe
vous avez vu ou si le virus passer d'une
ferme à l'autre on voyait le même virus
dans les fermes très éloignées les unes
des autres et des virus différents dans
des fermes voisines
encore aujourd'hui la propagation
demeure une énigme
l'équipe de marion kauffman n'écarte pas
la piste des insectes ou des oiseaux
sans attraper la maladie
ceux ci peuvent transporter le virus sur
leurs pattes d'une ferme à l'autre
surtout que ces installations comportent
souvent des ouvertures sur l'extérieur
malgré cela matthew moses est d'avis que
l'abattage massif ne serait pas indiqué
au canada tout simplement parce que la
densité des élevages est beaucoup moins
grande ici nous sommes dispersés à
travers tout le canada alors que la
superficie du danemark équivaut à peu
près à celle de la nouvelle écosse au
donc la concentration de vison et leur
répartition géographique n'ont rien à
voir il y à beaucoup plus de gens aussi
sur un même territoire
face à un ennemi commun les approches
varie donc grandement alors que le
danemark et les pays bas ont éliminé
leur cheptel
d'autres pays espère vacciner leur vison
la suède par exemple a annulé sa saison
de reproduction et conservent un minimum
de mâles et deux femelles pour
éventuellement relancer l'industrie
pendant ce temps en colombie-britannique
tout comme huit ce conseil le plus
important état producteur de fourrure de
vison aux états unis les éleveurs ont
été jugés travailleurs de première ligne
et ont obtenu un accès prioritaire aux
vaccins au canada tout comme aux états
unis
on a aussi fait le choix de ne pas
enterrer les animaux bord de la queue
vide mais de les congeler pour vendre
leur peau ultérieurement
depuis le début de la pandémie tous les
efforts ont été concentrés pour protéger
les humains mais beaucoup de chercheurs
le rappelle on est un animal parmi
d'autres et les virus qu'une cherche
après tout qu'à survivre ne font pas de
discrimination
non
si un agent infectieux qui rentrent en
contact avec un autre hôte dans lequel
il se reproduit plus facilement
il va sauter d'espèces hélène carabins
et vétérinaire épidémiologiste
on parlait de l'exceptionnalisme humain
avant b pour les agents infectieux yann
pop et si les vaccins sont des outils
très efficaces ils ont tout de même
leurs limites
en fait si on vaccine des humains on
élimine de l'humain on n'éradique pas
comme la grippe aviaire qui survit chez
les populations d'oiseaux sauvages et
refait périodiquement surface
l'aco vide pourrait elle aussi s'établir
à demeure chez d'autres espèces
qu'est ce que ça va faire dans un
réservoir animal personne ne sait donc
il faut vraiment établir des systèmes de
monitorage de surveillance pour
s'assurer que le virus revienne pas sous
une version modifiée si on veut contre
lesquels des vaccins fonctionneront plus
et pour voir venir les coups il faudrait
faire preuve de plus de transparence et
mieux partager les données à ce jour
impossible pour une chercheuse comme
marion kauffman de savoir par exemple où
sont situés les fermes de vison en
europe une information pourtant
primordial pour bien se préparer
il faut comprendre ce qui se passe du
côté des ennemis et éviter d'utiliser un
ton accusateur
vous savez les fermiers c'est seulement
de faire leur travail et ne veulent pas
non plus d'éclosion de co vide
il faut parler avec les éleveurs
puissent ça ça fait partie du concept
une seule santé ou si ces porcs ou
chercheurs ou au patron de dire vous
allez faire sa sauce les personnes qui
connaissent mieux leur élevage qui
connaissent mieux leurs animaux ce sont
des éleveurs eux-mêmes
c'est de plus en plus clair la santé
humaine la santé des animaux et celle de
l'environnement sont indissociables en
un an à peine un virus microscopique
venu probablement des confins de l'asie
a complètement bouleversé nos vies
lakovic 19 qui ne sera certainement pas
la dernière pandémie nous force donc à
repenser notre rapport
ce grand écosystème dont nous faisons
partie
la population mondiale augmente sans
cesse et pour se nourrir les gens se
tournent de plus en plus vers les
protéines animales comme les élevages
ont besoin d espace
on coupe des forêts et la faune sauvage
elle perd du terrain
cette cohabitation forcée provoque ou
accentuer le risque de nouvelles
maladies épidémiques
on pousse des espèces animales qui
traditionnellement n'était peut-être pas
en contact à venir en contact puis ci
s'avère que l'agent infectieux beit
rouge dans cette route respect ce le
moyen de se reproduire plus efficacement
il va faire le sou la majorité du temps
ça marche pas mais les quelques
exceptions où ça fonctionne comme celle
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui avec la coved
cette hyper efficace de strauss m qu'ils
restent là pourquoi aller ailleurs
j'aime bien dire qu'on doit arrêter de
penser de façon égocentrique igor scène
pour passer en mode eco centric
oui parce qu'après tout on partage cette
planète avec les animaux l'espace n'est
pas infinie alors on doit s'occuper
intelligemment
non
depuis les éclosions dans les fermes en
europe et en amérique du nord
de nombreuses voix s'élèvent tant au
sein des organismes de défense des
animaux que de la communauté
scientifique pour mettre fin à l'élevage
des visons on évoque des raisons à la
fois des tic et de santé publique